Good evening and a very warm welcome
to the Royal Library.
My name's Lise Back Hansen -
- and my colleagues and I are really happy
to see so many here tonight -
- for the International Authors' Stage
with Karl Ove Knausgård.
Also a warm welcome to the audience
watching our live stream -
- both to you at home
and all of you gathered at the libraries.
It's really great that we get together
to celebrate literature.
And it really is a celebration, actually.
This event is created in collaboration -
- with the Hans Christian Andersen
Award Prize Committee.
Every two years, this committee awards
a major international literature prize -
- which Karl Ove Knausgård
received in 2022.
And the awards committee
motivated the prize like this:
"He receives it for his intense renewal -
- of the field between
novel and autobiography -
- a field which Hans Christian Andersen
also explored -
- and for,
just like Hans Christian Andersen -
- positioning Scandinavia
on the literary world map."
Karl Ove Knausgård made his debut in 1998.
His works are translated into 36 languages
and are published all over the world.
But it is Knausgård's giant project
'My Struggle' -
- which he published in a series
of six autobiographical books -
- that established his name
internationally.
Recently, the novel series 'The Morning
Star', 'The Wolves of Eternity' -
- and most recently, 'Det tredje riket' -
- were all published in Danish
by Lindhardt and Ringhof.
We plan to talk about it all here tonight,
and I'm certainly looking forward to that.
For this purpose,
we've asked Kathrine Tschemerinsky -
- to interview Karl Ove Knausgård
about his work here on stage.
She has written about his writing
for a number of years -
- and she has read him
since he began writing.
And additionally, she's also
the culture editor at Weekendavisen.
In addition, the actor Benjamin Kitter
is also on stage.
He's here because we want to hear excerpts
from the works -
- and we want to hear it in the beautiful
Danish translation by Sara Koch.
Finally, I want to extend my warm thanks -
- to our excellent collaborators -
- the trade union DM
and the unemployment fund MA -
- that enable us to offer tickets cheaply
to students in our Students Only network.
I also want to praise the collaboration
with the H.C. Andersen prize committee -
- and of course, to Lindhardt and Ringhof.
An evening like this is only made possible
thanks to the great collaboration -
- within Danish culture.
Thank you so much.
So please welcome Karl Ove Knausgård,
Kathrine Tschemerinsky and Benjamin Kitter.
- Are you comfortable?
- I'm good.
We'll be here for a while.
Some years ago, quite a few years ago,
you wrote an essay -
- claiming that 'Madame Bovary'
was the best novel ever written.
Is that still your opinion?
It changes from week to week -
- but it's up there among the top ten.
Why is it that good?
It...
I'm trying to recapitulate and bring it
back. It's a long time since I read it.
It has an incredible visual precision.
A realistic precision.
And in all that precision,
it has something very imprecise -
- which is about a kind of desire...
Do you want to add something?
- Perhaps.
- We can return to it.
The reason I started by asking you
about this is -
- that tonight we'll talk about the novel
and first and foremost -
- we'll talk about how the novel
has taken shape in your work.
Do you remember the first time you became
aware there was something called a novel -
- and that it was different
from other forms of literature?
I remember...
I remember when I started reading novels -
- and I remember
how obsessed I was with it.
And I remember the first book
that made a difference.
It was a book by Ursula K Le Guin
called 'A Wizard of Earthsea' -
- that I received as a present
when I was ten.
I thought it was amazing,
and I read it again and again.
I've actually read it again as a grownup,
and I still think it's very good.
And I couldn't reflect on
why I thought it was important.
There was a kind of total involvement
and a total identification.
Among other things,
it's about haughtiness and transgression -
- but also about boundaries
between life and death.
And it's visualized and describes well
the transition into the land of the dead -
- and something from there
enters our world.
The protagonist,
who is young and haughty and ambitious -
- and is intelligent and gifted -
- wants to be a wizard.
This is before Harry Potter.
Many years before Harry Potter.
He attends a sort of wizard school,
but he goes too far.
He can do things that others can't and lets
something into the world that stalks him.
He then has to find the name
of whatever is pursuing him -
- that is driving him really far.
At the end of the book,
which for a ten-year-old was amazing -
- he sniffs at this creature
that threatens him -
- and then he sees his own name.
- Wow.
- That was it.
That meant...
Can you use a phrase like existentially
significant about a ten-year-old?
But that's what it was.
What was it about that book
that meant so much?
- About it?
- Yes.
There were these strong forces
in a person -
- that I didn't understand -
- but that I identified with
and experienced.
We'll now see a letter on the screen.
I told you about it the other day.
You asked me why do you send me this.
It's a letter from Hans Christian Andersen
that he sent to Charles Dickens in 1857 -
- after having spent five incredibly
long weeks with the Dickens family -
- and Dickens had him up to here.
He writes to thank him.
It ends with something I'll just read out -
- because I don't think anyone
can read the writing.
He says:
In my mind, I organize a new novel where
the humorous element will be prominent.
Of course, it takes place in our time.
I don't know any other.
It stays in Denmark,
there are my roots.
Live hearty well!
You asked me why I thought of you
when I stumbled upon that letter.
Normally when you talk
about writers and their novels -
- you imagine it's something
they've visualized way out on the horizon:
"I want to write this novel,"
and then they write that novel.
But what I think is so nice
about this letter from Andersen is -
- that in a way he is setting up
his own space of opportunity.
He recognizes that he can't write
like anyone about anything.
It made me want to ask you
what kind of author you can be -
- or have realized that you can be.
That I can be or want to be or am?
That you must be,
because you can't write any other way.
- What did you say?
- Because you can't write any other way.
For a long time, I couldn't write.
To begin with, I could write.
Writing was easy. I wrote lots.
It was incredibly immature and quite bad,
but it was just writing.
And then I got in touch
with the best literature.
I got into a writing academy.
Then suddenly I couldn't write anymore,
I saw what was good and what wasn't.
It was as if...
You may see in a lab,
they have an object inside a box -
- and stick their hands into gloves
and move things around. That's how I wrote.
It was quite distant
and quite rigid and quite mechanical.
And then...
... suddenly when I was 26,
I suddenly could write.
There were many reasons for that, however -
- what happened was
that writing became like reading.
So writing was the same as reading
when I grew up.
It was completely different.
It was something
I couldn't have thought out.
It was as if literature took over.
But it was very realistic.
It was very much based
on my own geography -
- a little my own family,
a little my own father.
Everything was there -
- a little changed,
but it was quite a realistic world.
I was in love with myself
because I could write.
At the end of it, a passage appears
that is fantastic, not realistic, fantastic.
It's about a world that doesn't exist.
People walk around with lynxes...
A fantastic universe.
When I wrote it, I thought -
- there was something there
that was really important for me.
My editor, Geir Gulliksen, said,
"We need to remove this. It doesn't fit in."
I said, "I want it in."
Then he wrote me a letter
and sent it by mail.
He's never done that,
neither before nor since -
- and said,
"Dear Karl Ove, can't we remove it?"
And I said, "No."
I always listen to him and do what he says,
but I said no.
The reason I said no
was that it was my first book -
- and this was an opportunity
I had in my writing.
I didn't want to be only a realistic author.
I wanted to be an author
who could write the fantastic.
Because I grew up
with the fantastic, right?
When I tried to become a writer, I tried
to write like Gabriel Garcia Marquez -
- or like Salman Rushdie
or one of the fantastic authors of the 80s.
I wanted both parts,
what is close and intimate -
- and that which is not, which is fantastic.
Which to me is literature.
That's why I was so happy
with my second book.
I thought, "Now I'm an author."
Because it's about angels that don't exist.
It's about something that doesn't exist.
But, they couldn't just be angels.
They had to exist in a specific place,
so they were placed in Norwegian nature -
- so it's the Bible in Norway.
It's well-known, but it's also literature.
There's a kind of duality that I think
is present in everything I've written.
After the point
where you find a way to write -
- do you have the feeling that you develop -
- in addition, of course,
to writing new books, I mean as an author?
Did you find a form?
Is it like a sweater you put on one day -
- and then you think,
"Wow, this sweater feels nice."
"Now I want to wear this
for the rest of my life." Or how is it?
It's as if...
If you write... or if you read a book -
- you want to read something that you could
not have foreseen, that you don't know -
- because if you know what's going
to happen, there's no reason to read it.
It's just like that when you write.
You sit down, there must be something
you don't know.
There must be something
that's interesting for you.
And when I'd written my debut book -
- it took five years before the next book,
and that's why.
It would just have been a continuation,
but I'd finished it.
I had to find a new place.
After the second book,
another five years passed. Same thing.
I really tried to write every day,
went to work, tried to write -
- it didn't work
because everything was known.
You need something unknown.
Then I started on 'My Struggle'.
You'd think that would be quite familiar.
You write about yourself. On the contrary.
And there I found a language
I hadn't used before -
- and it lasted six books.
I could've continued with 'My Struggle 7',
'My Struggle 8', 'My Struggle 9', but why?
There was nothing left there
that would be new.
Then I started writing short texts,
and I always wanted to do that.
When I grew up and started reading in the
90s when I wanted to become an author -
- minimalism and short texts
were important.
I read 'Punch' that wrote short texts
about things.
I thought it was excellent.
There were no people, only things.
But it was vibrant and incredibly good.
I wanted to write like that.
I sat down and made a list of maybe
200 things that I wanted to write about.
"I'll write about them."
There was nothing to write about.
After 'My Struggle',
I'd learned to lower the threshold -
- so that I'd accept everything that comes -
- so I sat down with a list of words
and then wrote short texts.
And it was 20 years later
or 15 years later.
And it's entirely different
from writing long autobiographically.
Even though the thoughts are the same,
and the way of writing is the same.
Just the form makes what you think
different in the text.
After that, I started on 'The Morning Star'.
It seems you always foresee that you must
change course because of your framework.
The short texts were a seasonal quartet -
- so right from the beginning,
you prepared for the end of the quartet.
The series you're working on now
with 'The Morning Star'...
I asked you how many volumes
you expect, and you said six.
Great! We can look forward
to three more books.
But you've established a framework:
It will end at some point.
You can't just keep writing
about the morning star forever.
Why? Is it then part of this idea
that you know you'll tire of it?
What you want is...
Ingmar Bergman,
the Swedish director, said -
- that the goal of a scene
was for it to create a new scene -
- that will create a new scene
and so forth.
You embark on something,
which is the creative process itself.
And that's what I want.
And so I have to set a framework or
a rule or... Not that it's very deliberate.
But, for example, in these books,
there are many different characters -
- that then give a very specific direction,
a specific way of thinking -
- and specific possibilities.
Actually, I had planned one book. It then
became three and then five and then six.
That's because the possibilities open up
as a result of that starting point.
You said before, when I asked how you found
out which author you could be -
- you said,
"Do you mean the ones I'd want to be?"
In essays you've written that you completely
stay away from certain authors -
- because they're so good -
- that being confronted with them
is unbearable.
Do you still feel that way
about certain authors -
- that you simply don't read them
because they're too good?
No, I've become more courageous,
so now I dare.
But the feeling is the same.
It's quite difficult, right?
But... by and large I read what I want.
Why have you become more courageous,
do you think?
- Why?
- Yes.
I think...
Yes, you talk about what kind of author
one wants to be. Okay.
Think about Hans Christian Andersen.
What kind of author was he?
He was...
He was full of energy -
- and he didn't seem to have
self-criticism.
It just came, right?
It just streamed through him.
He has left all kinds of things.
But there's not one work where you think,
"That's Hans Christian Andersen."
"We'll forget all the rest."
It's the whole package.
And if you look at his contemporary,
Søren Kierkegaard, it's the same thing.
There's an enormous energy
in all directions during a short period -
- when all his known works came out.
It's the same thing: You don't think
of one work but the whole package.
Think of August Strindberg in Sweden.
Same thing.
My ideal, and I'm not there,
is to write books, publish them -
- write the next one, publish it...
It's the very process, being in it,
that is the point.
If you think the authorship goes up there,
down there, in there, out there.
Then you have to let go of the idea
that everything should be terribly good.
That's cowardly, but I say,
"I don't have to write good books."
It's a way of guarding myself, if people say
it's bad, I say, "Yes. Never mind."
But it's also a way to manage
to write many books: to lower the threshold.
What comes here, I accept,
and then I write on.
Because when I couldn't
write for five years...
There were 800 pages of beginnings
with first pages or first sentences.
It never moved on.
That's what I've learned:
That's the kind of author I want to be.
The one who just writes.
Some months ago,
you gave a fabulous speech.
'Why the Novel Matters" was the title.
It was so weird listening to it.
It was later printed,
so you can find it on the web.
But it was so weird listening to it
because it suddenly dawned on me -
- how inspired you've been by the
high-modernist writers, Joyce and Woolf.
It was weird.
Like having friends that suddenly tell you
they're really into baking.
And you think, "What! I never knew."
And you realize afterward that they always
served you cakes they'd just baked.
But it made so much sense
that you were into those authors -
- and that they meant something to you.
But could you talk about that time
and those writers?
What have you taken with you from them?
Yes... that's interesting.
Because you read books.
And I never remember what I've read -
- but I read -
- and I write.
Then... back to that story again
when I couldn't write and hadn't debuted -
- I read Marcel Proust.
Discovered Marcel Proust. I was obsessed.
I read him all summer.
I had no money. I was drinking water
in cafes reading Marcel Proust.
Absolutely excellent.
Two years later, I debuted as an author.
I didn't see a correlation, but now I see
that I have taken everything from there.
The whole way of thinking literature,
the way of thinking metaphors.
For he is one who opens up all the time,
right?
When I started writing,
minimalism was the thing.
If it was bad, you had to delete the bad.
The idea was that what was left
should be really good.
But with Proust it's the opposite.
He adds and adds and adds
and expands.
He might have a scene.
A scene like this with people.
He may make this look
like something under water -
- with anemones and things like that.
There's a light somewhere.
With just one metaphor,
he's established two worlds, one here -
- and an underwater world, and then
you can be in that underwater world.
You can open world after world after world.
They're all next to each other.
With a metaphor you can lift it in
and open room after room.
It's totally contrary to minimalism, right?
But I wasn't aware that
that's where it came from. But it was.
I also read Joyce -
- when I studied literature
in Bergen in the 90s.
I was 20 and don't think
I understood a lot of it.
It's not that it's difficult
but it's unusual.
I've returned to that book time and again.
I've read it multiple times.
And because it takes place on one day -
- it's like...
There's a whole world,
a whole universe -
- that plays out on that day,
but it doesn't have access to the story -
- only to the story that takes place right
now. There's really no superstructure.
Everything is just
splinters and fragments around -
- just like we live our lives.
Superstructures and ideologies don't exist.
It's always here and now, right?
That's a fundamental insight from that book.
When I wrote that essay, it's about
that these books, such as Joyce -
- enter the world
before it has become history -
- before it's been thought,
"This is the way it is."
It enters
while it's still coming into being.
Just as I have no idea what
you're going to say in one minute.
No clue. I don't know, right? It will
happen, but I don't know what it'll be.
That's where Joyce enters. Right there.
And that's where we live and exist.
And oddly,
Virginia Woolf does the same thing.
That's why they're so good:
they're about nothing.
There's Bloom having breakfast,
going to the bathroom -
- going out into the streets,
thinking a little.
Nothing happens,
but that's what life is.
And through the novel,
he manages to get in there.
In the same essay, I use another example -
- which is a book that's very topical now,
it's from Ukraine -
- at around 2014-15 in the Donbass area -
- before the war escalated,
but there was still a war then.
We've read lots
of journalistic reportage from there.
On-the-spot journalistic reportage:
"This is what it's like, this happens."
"This happens. We are in control.
We know how it is."
He goes in and is there.
Nothing's happened yet.
There is nothing.
Some may be enemies, not enemies.
Some speak Russian, some speak Ukrainian.
Don't know. It's a kind of no-man's land.
It seems very strong when you contrast it
with the way we perceive the world -
- through journalism.
We think we know what's going on,
right?
If there's a conflict,
we know what's going on.
But being there is something else entirely,
and that's what novels can do.
They can open up that space, I think.
That's a good point.
His name is Serhiy Zhadan.
Now is a good time
to have the first excerpt read out.
It's from 'Det tredje riket',
which was published in Danish last week.
It's the third volume
of 'The Morning Star' series.
The passage we'll hear
tells about a young woman.
Let's hear it.
Mom was washing the dishes
when I came down.
Judging by the sound, Grandma
was in the living room watching TV -
- if she wasn't just sleeping.
- "I'll take a walk," I said.
- "Do that," Mom said.
"Where are you going?"
What did she want with that information?
"Up to the waterfall, perhaps," I said.
Mom nodded, and I went outside -
- toward what Thomas and I had called
the troll forest when we were kids.
A lot of age-old spruce stood very close -
- dark even in the middle of the day.
No, not dark, shadowy. Always quiet.
Long veils hanging from the branches.
Thick moss like blankets on the stones.
I thought of Valdemar as I walked.
He should have seen it.
My heart bounced like a tiny hare.
If he was like everyone else, I'd have taken
a picture of the forest. Sent it to him.
Just the picture. No comments or anything.
But he's not like everyone else.
Am I?
Before I met Valdemar,
I would've said yes.
Yes, I'm like everyone else.
But he says I'm not like them.
I'm not so stupid that I don't understand
that's what men tell women -
- when they want them:
"You're not like everyone else."
"You're very special."
Wind one hour forward and that's it:
"You're lovely," they say.
But Valdemar is not like that.
He always says what he means.
That doesn't mean he's right when
it comes to me. Only that he means it.
A shadow of despair
followed every thought of Valdemar.
What should I do?
What on earth should I do?
Even in there, where the trees
shut out the sun, it was hot.
Swarms of insects danced in the air.
In the roar of the waterfall,
dark shadows were moving around.
Small trout.
I sat down on a rock and looked at them.
After a few seconds,
I reached into my pocket for the phone -
- before I remembered
that I'd left it at home.
Missing it suddenly panged me,
even though I'd left it at home on purpose.
One of the fish came to the surface,
the back gray and speckled -
- like the stones around it.
I forced myself to stay seated.
Looked up the mountainside
where the waterfall came gushing down.
The trees on top shone in the light
of the last rays of the sun.
Of all the places in the world,
I always liked best to be here -
- with Grandma and Grandpa.
Especially when Thomas and I
were alone with them.
It was pure bliss.
A winter vacation
when the lake was frozen over -
- and we skated
and got to know the other kids in the area.
A couple of summer vacations
when Mom and Dad were in Germany.
Now Grandpa is dead and Grandma so sick that
she probably won't live through the winter.
Thomas sat in his room and saw no one.
Dad drank himself to death in Portugal.
And Mom pretended
that everything was fine.
The hand searched for the phone again.
A new little slip of disappointment
that it wasn't there.
I looked over at the woods
on the other side.
A little further inside,
there were large stones -
- that Grandpa used to say were trolls -
- who hadn't made it into the mountain
before the sun rose.
We wanted to believe him,
and then it became that way.
Gleefully, we balanced on the dead
trolls, secure as long as the sun was up.
We asked him if they could come alive
again once the sun went down.
In a serious voice, he said
he didn't know.
Dad couldn't stand Mom's father.
When I was little, I couldn't understand it.
Grandpa was incredible.
Full of stories that just flowed out of him.
And he laughed so much.
Presumably, he didn't like Dad,
and Dad, of course, understood that.
And then it became that he didn't like
Grandpa. Not the other way around.
When Grandma got Parkinson's,
Dad told me it was hereditary -
- and that if I got it as an adult,
I had to understand -
- it didn't come from his side
of the family.
What a thing to tell an eight-year-old.
The movements
in the waterfall had ceased -
- and I spent some time
trying to find the fish again.
They stood perfectly still
just above the bottom.
I took a rock, bent over the water -
- and dropped it over one of them
like a depth charge.
It hurried off long before the rock hit it.
I rinsed my face.
The water wasn't much cooler
than the warm air -
- but enough for it to feel cool.
I didn't feel like going back to Mom
and Grandma -
- but I couldn't sit there all evening
either.
Had used up my half hour on the phone,
but if I spent half an hour now -
- I could drop half an hour in the morning.
It would come to the same thing.
Valdemar had told a story about Hitler.
They'd talked about charisma.
Hitler had had a strong charisma,
Gerhardt had said.
People wanted to be with him.
Valdemar had read a book
that Hitler's architect had written.
He was completely infatuated, Valdemar said.
But when he introduced his father to 'the
man', the father turned completely pale.
He said Hitler was a dangerous man.
He'd seen something no one else saw.
"He sounds a bit like Dad," I said.
Valdemar laughed.
He didn't do that very often.
"You live in your own little bubble,"
he said.
I felt stupid. He saw that.
"Hitler was just a human being," he said.
"Just like your father."
Valdemar wasn't a Nazi
though many thought so.
When he talked about the Third Reich,
he wasn't talking about the Nazis -
- but something they had believed in
in the Middle Ages.
That the First Kingdom was the era of God.
The Second Kingdom was the era of Jesus.
And the Third Kingdom
was the era of the Holy Spirit.
"We're entering the Third Kingdom,"
he'd said. Not to me, but to the others.
When you hear this passage,
you get the impression -
- Line, the young woman
has fallen in love with Valdemar -
- the lead singer in a Norwegian black metal
band who has some very occult ideas...
You get the impression that this book
deals with some of the same ideas -
- that you talked about before:
Being in the moment, being in her thoughts
as it looks in the now.
I was thinking...
When you wrote this, what...
What is it with this moment?
In 'The Morning Star', a star has appeared
that wasn't there before.
People think about their private problems,
the ones they've fallen in love with.
In the second book,
the first part takes place in 1987.
Chernobyl has just exploded,
and it's mentioned on the radio -
- but it's out in the horizon.
Again, it's the idea of history.
History, all the important things
that we talk about many years later -
- take place in the periphery.
Please talk about
how you use that in this new work.
- How I use the star?
- History and the moment, I'd say.
As two opposites.
I don't know.
Actually, I don't know.
I'm not thinking in those categories
when I write.
Here there was a character
that I knew was 19 years old -
- and that I knew had a mother
who took care of her mother.
And I knew that something had happened.
And I knew
that it had to be something extreme.
I didn't know more than that.
I had no background, no nothing.
She sat down -
- and then there's the stones
that the grandfather talked about -
- and then it unfolds.
Then there's this Valdemar. Who is he?
I don't know.
Then I write when she meets him.
And there's this Nazi thing about him.
There were rumors about him. He's one
that people talk about. He's not good.
But she's in love with him. And that adds
a dynamic that is good to work with, right?
Very ambivalent, very good feelings,
very terrible feelings.
He finally invites her to Sweden -
- to a farm.
There are lots of people there.
It's almost like a sect.
It turns out he's playing in a band,
and they're going to perform.
They've never published their music.
It's a secret.
But there's this live concert,
and it's absolutely incredible.
But they're totally anti-commercial.
Totally anti our time.
It comes when I write.
And then it comes that he's charismatic.
And then I remember the story
about Hitler and his architect -
- because it's in his biography.
He liked Hitler,
and Hitler was charming and charismatic -
- and then there was his father
who was white as a sheet.
Something scary.
I was always attracted to that story,
because it contains this ambivalence.
And then I use it.
I take all I've got and throw it all in.
So it sort of appears out of the fog
when you write?
Yes, all the time.
I never know...
And many things come from 'My Struggle'.
Many thoughts from 'My Struggle'.
Things I've written in the past.
But the point is that it all appears
in different characters -
- so they become different.
And writing about
a 19-year-old girl in love -
- I couldn't have done
before I started on this project.
It would never work.
I wouldn't dare.
But I thought there was something there,
a tone.
She's quite innocent, but has her own will.
She wants her own life.
How that vulnerability
manifests itself in the novel...
I'm not thinking about the story
or anything else.
It's incredible to read your works
chronologically -
- because one begins to see some elements
that appear.
They're not repetitions, more like...
They appear like small stones in the sand,
where I think: "I've seen this before."
It may be a small sentence that is repeated.
Or a character trait or ideas.
One idea
I've seen circulating all the way.
You see it in the angel book. You see
it in 'My Struggle' and in the new one.
It's the idea that humans create clearings -
- and then we surrender,
and then darkness arrives.
You formulate it in different ways,
but it's the idea of the return of evil.
In the newest work, it's really let loose.
That idea, why has it been so important
and for so long?
I don't believe...
I don't believe in evil as a concept.
What does that mean?
I don't believe in a general evil.
But I believe there is a human trait...
It's always been an interesting question
for me: "How do we become what we become?"
In 'The Morning Star', I have a character
called Jostein who's really unpleasant.
He's sexist, vulgar,
he's everything you don't want to be.
How did he become like that?
Once he was two years old and not like that.
What happened?
There's something in the personality, then
layer upon layer of experiences are added -
- and you maneuver among them,
and suddenly at 50 you're in a place that...
You're just there, right?
But with him I thought okay,
if I reverse it -
- I'll send him to the land of the dead.
In ancient mythology, there's a thing
called the River of Forgetfulness.
If you drink from it, you forget everything.
He drinks from it and forgets everything.
Who is he then?
He doesn't remember anything.
Where is his character? He has none.
He's not evil.
You can imagine that all this comes back.
It's the characters and what exists
in the characters that interest me.
But there's another kind of evil,
or you may call it original sin -
- or something
which is also very interesting:
We as humans
do a lot of things collectively.
It doesn't have to be evil,
but the consequences follow like a tail -
- that we don't know about.
Like for instance... the car.
We invent the car.
A great invention.
We can go where we want to. Visit people.
We become very mobile -
- and acquire a very different culture,
where everything is more accessible.
It's great.
And the darkness comes up from behind.
Nobody wanted that. Nobody thought of that.
But now we see it with the climate crisis -
- which is a kind of connection
between what we do and what happens.
That which is us and that which will come
have nothing to do with us, individually -
- but have to do with the collective.
The French philosopher Michel Serres
talks about that as the original sin.
That is the original sin.
You might consider artificial intelligence
that is changing so much.
It uses the collective.
There's no individuality.
It uses all the collective that's out there.
It's fed to it,
and then it produces something out of it.
But it's really operating in something
that's among us.
We don't know what the consequences are.
We haven't got a clue.
You say this is a kind of evil.
Impersonal evil.
The evil consequences
of our collective actions.
But what mostly interests me
is the one on one.
What happens to us, and what makes us
what we are and makes us do what we do.
You can think of heads of state, Putin
or your terrible neighbor -
- or your good one.
What is actually happening?
In your new work...
Your books have always had
a great number of characters -
- but in this new work one enters the head
of very many people.
Perhaps it's not a decision -
- but to move from 'My Struggle'
where there's one "I", you might say...
- to a work where there are,
so far, almost 20.
Why has this change taken place
in your work?
That's why.
Before I'd completely emptied
being one person.
The whole world is in one person.
There are books, movies, other people,
culture, politics, all kinds of things.
But after all, it's one way
of seeing the world.
And I thought, everybody's like that.
If you have different people,
everything's there.
Then there's another person who's got the
same things but perceives them differently.
That creates a relationship, a dynamic -
- where the world starts to look relative.
If you think about being together
with people that are close to you.
You know each other really well.
And you start to quarrel.
Something's happened,
but you see it completely differently.
It's always fascinated me
how that is possible.
If we share everything, and then
something's completely opposite.
The way it's understood.
In these books with all these characters,
this is exactly what's happening:
Not who we are for ourselves
but for each other.
I've been sitting here for perhaps an hour -
- but I already have a picture
of who your are -
- and I've heard what you've said.
I created an image of who you are.
It's not much, but here we are.
But... I don't have any...
People show very little
of this enormous inner life -
- and in a way that's the dynamic
that I write about.
So for instance, in the book
there's a literature professor, Arne -
- who's married to an artist called Tove.
They've been married for a long time.
Arne is a little tired of Tove.
That's the way it is.
Then in the third book, you see everything
from Tove's point of view -
- and everything looks different.
There's another couple. Kathrine is a
pastor. Gaute is a teacher. They're married.
You get Kathrine's version, and
in the third book you get Gaute's version -
- that looks quite different.
But they're looking at the same thing.
The idea behind 'The Morning Star is
that all these people live their lives -
- have their opinions -
- and they look at the same thing outside
that no one knows what is.
One character is a complete surprise,
of course, the Russian biologist -
- that suddenly turns up in the second book.
When I read that, I had to call one of my
friends who was also reading the book -
- and say: "Listen, it's totally wild.
He's written about a Russian lady."
In 2023, I don't know why,
but it seemed so wild -
- particularly
when you come from writing about yourself.
Was it difficult to write
a Russian woman character?
Why was she there?
Yes...
When I started on the book, 'The Wolves
of Eternity', I didn't know what to write.
I went through old things I'd written -
- and found a manuscript from 2012
with 30 pages about a character...
I'd forgotten that I wrote it,
and I'd never shown it to anyone -
- because I thought it was so bad.
Usually, I show everything to my editor,
but not this.
It's about Syvert.
He came back from the military.
He had a mother, his father was dead,
and a brother. 30 pages.
I read it again and thought...
I liked the character.
He's good-natured, he's jovial,
he's extrovert -
- all that I'm not,
and that I've written about.
I thought okay,
I'll see what happens then.
At the same time,
I read a book about Russia.
A social anthropologist called Bernstein
had written a book about Russia.
It mentioned a demonstration in Moscow
against death.
With posters and speeches.
They were against death.
I read on and learned that this is actually
a kind of culture -
- and ideology in Russia -
- that began at the end of the 1800s with
a specific philosopher called Fyodorov -
- that Dostoyevsky admired
and that Tolstoy wanted to befriend.
He was incredibly interesting.
An ascetic who lived for this one idea...
If all human beings join all their forces
and work on this one thing -
- perhaps we can raise the dead.
All of them. It should be possible, right?
We would have to collect all the atoms
and do it.
It's a crazy idea, but Dostoyevsky
took it seriously. It's about resurrection.
Since then, this idea has existed
in Russian culture.
As far as the novel is concerned,
I have a Norwegian person, 20 years old -
- a nice guy -
- and the novel has to go to Russia,
because I want to write about this.
So I had to find the way to go there -
- and then the father, who's dead,
has exchanged letters -
- with a Russian woman.
I go to Russia -
- and there was a room,
and I knew she'd be around 40.
I'm looking down. I didn't even know
what I had to work with.
I'm looking out at the street,
it's snowing in Moscow.
She hears someone in the next room.
It's the son, he's 19.
I'm thinking, biologist, perhaps, because
I'm interested in the beginning of life -
- instead of death like in the first book.
Where are you going?
You'll be lecturing at the university.
Basic studies,
because she's hasn't been doing so well.
Then it's on its way.
I was in Russia for nine days,
and I used the nine days to the full -
- so everything is authentic with locations,
etc.
It was very risky.
I have no idea about how a woman thinks.
I have no idea how a Russian thinks.
or about biology.
But I threw myself at it -
- and then I sent
the manuscript to my cousin -
- who's lived in Russia and speaks Russian
and to my Russian translator -
- and asked them to read it and comment it.
The comments were extremely practical.
The practical is always
where you make mistakes.
The character takes the train in Russia,
goes to the restroom -
- and there's toilet paper.
It would never happen.
So the toilet paper is written out.
Things like that.
Now we'll return to the angel book,
'A Time for Everything'.
You write something quite amazing about
this fictional angel researcher, Bellori.
You write that to understand him
one has to know his time.
An author can learn something about
someone by understanding who they were -
- but the most interesting is their time
and the place they hail from.
You also wrote the same
in an essay about Dag Solstad.
If you were to explain, what is your time?
I don't mean the entire epoch -
- but do you have a special time
that is more yours than other times?
I do. Because when I started on the second
book, 'The Wolves of Eternity', it's 1986 -
- I was about 18-19 years old...
Wait, 18-19... 1986... Yes, 19.
18-19.
And the book I'm writing now, that's lucky,
because it also takes place in 1986.
In London.
But it's because I know that time
a hundred percent, somehow.
It's quite natural.
I think it's because when you're 20,
your world is finalized.
You're in the world in a way.
You're in control.
And then you're mistaken,
because the world changes -
- but you only actually have what you had
when you were 20.
Everything else becomes a little panicky.
You constantly have to catch up.
I think it's when you're 20
that your time is created.
Everything else is
things that come against you.
- Aftertime.
- Yes, I don't quite know what that is.
It's just my theory. That's how I see it.
And mentally, I stopped when I was 20.
What about place? You've lived outside
of Norway a great part of your life.
You called it an exile. You lived in Sweden,
now you live in London.
What is the real location for you?
There are two locations, I think.
One is the place I hail from,
Southern Norway.
The other place is home, the family.
That's what is home in a way.
Some have defined home as a place -
- where they can't deny you entry.
That's home.
It is the family, and it may be anywhere.
It may be London or somewhere else.
You're one of the authors that I know
who've used most space -
- to describe the art of others -
- and describe how it affects you.
It's this interest
in what meeting great art does to you.
Can you talk about what it does -
- when you see a picture or read a book -
- or listen to music?
Yes, it...
I've always thought it's so strange -
- that a picture
can arouse such strong feelings.
You've probably tried to draw
and paint yourself. Me too.
Nothing happens.
But then you may look at a picture
of an apple, for instance -
- or a glass of water...
actually, anything -
- and it arouses so much,
and therefore I try to write about it -
- try to find out what's at stake, actually.
When you write novels you use words,
concepts -
- you use intellect, thoughts.
But you don't communicate directly.
Music and visual arts
go directly to the heart.
It's actually only feelings, nothing else.
That's a fundamental question:
What is it? Why?
That's the starting point -
- and then I wrote about specific arts
that are very different.
Do you think one becomes a better
human being by looking at great art?
Or read great art?
If you do that... I don't think
you become a better human being -
- but I think
the world becomes less simple -
- and that's important -
- because the simple answers,
the simple solutions -
- simple politics -
- that's no good in art.
Everything becomes complicated
and multi-faceted -
- and that's a good thing.
It's one of the things that art really does.
It's a little like
what I said about the novel:
It enters before the world is created,
when it's still being created.
I've said that:
Real art is the opposite of Nazism.
Absolutely the opposite.
Though Nazism too operates
with very strong feelings, obviously.
We'll now again listen to Benjamin.
He'll read
from the sixth volume of 'My Struggle'.
In this passage -
- Karl Ove, the story-teller,
is talking to his friend Geir.
The children are running around.
They're preparing food.
And they're talking about various things.
That's what we'll hear now.
"Do you want a beer or what?" Geir said
when I got back into the kitchen.
"Why not?"
"So we're structuring the social space,"
he said, opening the refrigerator door.
I sat down. He passed me a beer.
"We thoroughly design the physical space."
"We have elevated awareness of everything.
Who designed the fork we eat with, we know."
"We eliminate all dangers
and take precautions for everything."
"What disappears is spontaneity."
"Why do we want spontaneity to go away?
What do we achieve by that?"
"Spontaneity is unpredictable. It can't be
repeated. Repetition is the key to control."
"There we are."
"In a way, the circle is joined," I said.
"What do you mean?"
"Neanderthals," I said.
"Your favorite subject."
"What insight have you gleaned
from their sorry lives today, I wonder?"
"Do you think they were spontaneous?"
"When you ask like that,
the answer is probably no."
"During the 200,000 years they lived
in Europe, they didn't develop at all."
"They did exactly the same thing
when they came, in exactly the same way -
- as they did when they disappeared.
They even lived in exactly the same places."
"In a cave in France,
a tribe lived for 40,000 years."
"They only disappeared
when the cave collapsed."
"It's like one family living on a farm
for forty thousand years."
"It is utterly unthinkable.
But not for them."
"They made the same tools. They hunted
the same way. They ate the same food."
"Not one thing about them changed."
"It's fascinating, isn't it? That our
closest relatives were unable to change."
"That progress was a totally
foreign concept to them."
"No improvisation. No spontaneity.
It didn't exist."
"The first humans represented
an unimaginable revolution when they came."
"What separated us from them was precisely
what we are now trying to remove."
"Now you have to say it's not so long
since the first humans arrived."
"Yes, but it isn't."
"Back then many different kinds of humans
lived side by side. It'll happen again."
"If you're thinking, let's say,
three hundred thousand years ahead."
"There should be other types of humans.
Perhaps already after sixty thousand years."
"Yes, give them my regards."
"Ha ha. But do you know how many
Neanderthals there were?"
"No."
"A high guess will be 20,000.
A low one, ten thousand."
"Somewhere in between.
And that was all of them."
"Just think what Europe looked like."
"Totally without humans.
Only animals and birds, forests and plains."
"And then 15,000 stubborn Neanderthals
scattered in caves around the continent."
- "Your utopia?"
- "Almost."
"But the main difference between
the first humans and the Neanderthals..."
"You know what it was?"
"They didn't have frankfurters."
"Humans wore jewelry."
"They wore teeth from the dead around
their necks. They thought in symbols."
"There are more things in Heaven and Earth."
"It was an unthinkable thought
for the Neanderthals."
"One wonders what the idea of it all is,"
Geir said. "Teeth around the neck."
- "It means that something more exists."
- "That's precisely what makes me think."
"The teeth are just teeth."
"The Neanderthal existence in the world
seems to me more adequate."
"There are probably Neanderthal genes
in our DNA."
"Not in Africans', since there were
no humans when Neanderthals left Africa."
"But in Europeans' DNA.
I don't think Neanderthals went extinct."
"I think they mingled with humans
and disappeared into them."
"You think so?"
"Yes. At least that's not implausible."
"And so far, Neanderthals have been here
longer than us."
- "But they didn't know about that."
- "No, they probably didn't."
"So we've gone from a world without
mystery to a world full of mysteries -
- and back to a world
without mystery again."
"It's incredible that the state pays
people like you to sit and ponder all day -
- and then write books
about what you've thought about."
"There was a small human race on Flores,
an island in Indonesia."
"They lived in a cave. Probably, they were
no more than 50 to 100 individuals."
"About a meter tall."
- "Dwarfs?"
- "No."
"They were simply a completely different
human race."
"They lived there
well into the age of humans."
"And among those who live there now,
strange stories are circulating -
- about little people
stealing their vegetables?"
"I heard a tale like that."
"He said the women threw their breasts
over their shoulders when they ran."
"Where the hell did that detail come from?"
"When he told about them, they
sounded like some kind of little trolls -
- or, yes, creatures from mythology.
Infernal or something."
"But then they found little skeletons
in the cave. Small mini humans."
"Where do you know all this from?"
"They broadcast such documentaries at night.
I look a lot at things like that."
"I don't know how much is true and how much
is nonsense, but it's incredibly exciting."
"Yes, apparently."
"It's about the utopians, I think.
It was actually different then."
"Not only the environment,
but also the human itself."
"I just want alternatives.
Anything actually."
"So you want to be a Neanderthal.
Is that what you're saying?"
"No. But the fact that history is over
and there is no other future -
- except the repetition
of what we have now -
- every now then makes me almost sick
with claustrophobia."
"I don't necessarily have to do anything
else or be anything else. That's not it."
"But I want the possibility
that a completely different life exists."
"We live in a period of zero visions.
It also means we have zero visions."
"You got lucky with that one."
I got up and went into the living room.
Geir followed.
'Bolibompa' had finished.
Now they were looking a youth program.
I switched the TV off and looked at Geir.
"Should we give them a bath?"
This is such a cool passage.
Absolutely wild.
There are several reasons
why I included it today.
One is that it contains the wording:
"I just want alternatives."
It's one of the ideas
that are repeated in your work:
The yearning for something different.
The idea that another world is possible.
Why do you keep saying that
and make your characters shout it out?
Because I feel it so strongly.
You never know, if you feel something -
- if that feeling is general
or if it's just personal.
But I've had the feeling -
- that the future
will just be more of the same.
We can't imagine another future -
- or that something will happen
that will change -
- or that there'll be
a kind of utopian dimension.
I've got the feeling that this is it -
- and there'll be more of this.
Things won't change.
But the crazy thing is that
things have never changed as much -
- as they have over the last 10-15 years.
It's boom, boom, new things constantly.
Our entire social world
has been turned upside down -
- and yet I feel and think:
It'll never change.
It'll always be the same.
And that is something
I want to write about and that interests me.
With those feelings, I began to read -
- an English music journalist
and academic and theorist -
- Mark Fisher.
He writes a lot about
what he calls the hauntology -
- that the past comes up from the back
and takes us.
With technology, it's as if the past
is in the present -
- accessible.
Popular culture is the 90s or the 2000s,
we can use everything -
- concurrently, in parallel, and we do.
In a way, it's as if the past
has taken over the entire space.
There's no room for the future.
It's a sentiment. It's not real.
It's just a feeling that I write about.
But what was so upsetting by rereading
this passage from 'My Struggle' -
- was reading about the idea
that we're at the end of history and say:
"Yes, that's how it once was."
Then you bring out
the 'Morning Star' series -
- and formulate
an entirely new perception of time -
- similar to what Solvej Balle does:
something's happening these years.
The feeling that the future is out there,
and we don't know what's coming.
It's strange to read a book
where suddenly a morning star appears.
It's supernatural.
But it's as if you'd written
a realistic novel -
- it would've felt more fictional
than the supernatural.
The supernatural novel expresses
what it feels like to be human right now.
It's funny that you mention Solvej Balle.
Two years ago I was in Copenhagen.
I'd heard about Solvej Balle in the 90s
and had read about her -
- and I saw a book in a store and bought it.
I started to read,
and read three books in one go.
Fabulous. Absolutely
incredibly, incredibly, incredibly good.
When I read it I didn't know why.
"I just have to read this."
From any point of view,
it's an absolutely incredibly good series.
But what happens?
The same day returns again and again.
There's is no future, right?
It's exactly the same feeling,
just expressed so much better -
- and precisely,
as a metaphor and a perfect novel -
- because that's what a perfect novel does.
It manages to encompass the entire epoch,
the entire emotion in one image.
And then you continue with that.
It took almost a year
after I'd read that book...
That's it. That's what it's about. That's
why I like it so much. Among other things.
If she'd done like me and said:
"Blah-blah-blah, the future blah-blah,"
it wouldn't work.
But here you get a great,
existential experience -
- from reading this fictional work.
It has such an appeal.
Don't you agree?
Perhaps yours too. I think so.
Do you see why the two works...
Do you see the connection to your own
work when you think of Solvej Balle?
Or do you see her
as something completely different?
If I see the connection
between Solvej Balle...?
Between 'The Morning Star' and her book.
On the on hand, when I read her book -
- I just read
and think it's absolutely fabulous.
On the other, I'm incredibly jealous.
"Why don't I do that?"
I throw away all my energy on this,
while this exists.
Really, that's how it feels.
It's terrible.
I still think it's good that you read it.
We were to talk in November.
Then it was canceled.
In a way I'm very happy that happened
and that we're sitting here now -
- because in the meantime something
absolutely wild has happened -
- which is artificial intelligence -
- and the development that started
in December when ChatGPT came out.
Almost every day something new is happening.
I think that development reveals something
else in your work -
- which is that from the beginning
it was about human consciousness.
It was about the human essence,
you might say.
It's been about what thoughts look like.
That's a thing you explore
in 'Det tredje riket'.
When you think about
the consequences of all these new things -
- can you say something about that?
What these books are about,
somewhat in the background -
- but that I want to incorporate -
- is quite simply
that man and machine grow together.
They get ever closer.
Technology and biology come nearer
and nearer and infiltrate each other.
It's terrible to work on such a project,
and then something like this happens -
- which is like a new step of the machine
closing in on consciousness.
This is the dystopian element
in these books, I thought -
- but reality is more dystopian.
What should I say...?
Six months ago, a friend of mine...
He works with technology.
He said, "Soon machines
will be able to write your books."
I said, "No, come on. Don't be stupid.
That's ridiculous."
"Are you such a technological optimist?"
Then this happens, and he sends me a text -
- where he's asked artificial intelligence
to write in my style.
And I receive a text in my style
written by a machine.
- Was it good?
- What should I say?
It lacks soul.
But it's...
But one issue when talking about novels is,
will people stop writing novels?
No, the opposite will happen.
Precisely the opposite will happen.
The human, the attentive, which before was
called the soul will be much more important.
Obviously, what artificial intelligence does
is to collect what already exists.
It's like an enormous sea of the collective
subconscious that it feeds on.
But it can't be attentive
like a human being.
If it gets to that...
many believe that it will become conscious -
- then it'll be a human.
But what's interesting,
and what these books deal with is -
- if we can imagine
other kinds of intelligence.
Could we think that the forest
is one type of intelligence -
- which is so outlandish that
we don't even understand it as intelligence?
It's not long ago that we started
to understand that trees have a memory.
Trees may actually have something
similar to thoughts.
It was unthinkable 15 years ago.
Now it's accepted.
We know much more about how it happens.
We know that trees communicate.
And...
Is artificial intelligence another form of
intelligence, and we don't know what it is?
The problem is that we actually don't know
what ordinary intelligence is.
We don't know what consciousness is.
I've studied consciousness, because a person
is studying consciousness in this book -
- and so I've taken an interest.
The more you read, the more you realize
that no one knows what it is.
No one knows what it takes. At the same
time, it's the only thing we have.
Our only value is consciousness,
because that's what we see the world with.
It's a total mystery.
Just a simple thing like that.
The novel has always been
this strange parasite -
- that jumped onto people
throughout history -
- and then the form changes
along the way.
If we say that this development
with artificial intelligence...
People, authors keep writing novels.
Could you imagine that an inner change
will take place in the novel?
What I mean is that over the course
of the 20th century, God died -
- and most authors related to the fact
that there was not this outer force.
That also influenced
how novels were written -
- because the external voice
did not make sense anymore.
If we accept that artificial intelligence
exists now... It's an external voice.
To explain something,
you need something on a higher level.
Do you think it'll change the novel
in this way?
If you think again about 'Madame Bovary' -
- the question is what it's about.
It's difficult to say.
In essence, it's about reality -
- and a depiction of reality.
Reality and a fiction
meeting in the fiction.
You might ask, "What is real?"
And 'Don Quixote', the first novel,
what is that about?
It's about someone
who has a fantasy image of reality -
- that crashes against reality.
That's the first novel.
What is real?
That's the novel's question -
- which it can elaborate on in all kinds
of ways and forms and genres, etc.
But it will be even more essential
to ask oneself about that now:
What is real?
What does it mean to be real?
What difference will it make to read
a book written by artificial intelligence -
- if it moves me?
If it makes me laugh?
Where are we?
What is real?
That's the novel's real question.
I don't think it'll change anything,
it'll just make the conflict more critical.
Is there something you haven't yet
written about where you think:
"I have to write about this?"
Yes...
Yes, there is.
But it's more that I want to be wilder.
For instance, I love 'Dracula'.
Bram Stoker's 'Dracula'.
I'd love to be completely gothic and wild -
- while it has to be believable.
It has to work.
When I started on 'Morning Star',
it was a small goal -
- that I should send two people out to
the churchyard in a night with lightning -
- and they would dig up a corpse
to check...
I'm on my way there.
That's what the novel is also about, and
I think for many, to allow for something.
It's not about saying something.
That's easy.
But it's about creating a space
where what you say is important.
I think that's important for the novel.
Another starting point was:
Is it possible nowadays to write a novel -
- where the Devil exists, and it works
and is something I want to read about.
It's also part of my attempt to get there.
- How far can you go before the reader...
- "That's not believable."
My favorite Norwegian author,
Thure Erik Lund.
He's fabulous.
I interviewed him once.
He described his ideal novel -
- as a novel where everything keeps
changing, where also the reader changes -
- so that the novel in the end
might be in Chinese -
- and the reader knew Chinese.
That's the ideal novel.
He's wild.
He's a top author.
Now you'll read from 'Det tredje riket'.
Before that, I'll just say that if someone
wants to buy the book and have it signed -
- it can be done in the library shop
in a moment.
- Now it's time for you to read.
- Yes.
I'll read a little about Tove -
- who started out
as a supporting character -
- but took on a growing role and is now one
of the main characters in these books.
She's a painter.
That afternoon,
I found a perfect place in the forest.
A naked, steep mountain wall
at the bottom of an incline -
- that opened up onto a narrow ravine.
I brought with me
a half-full bucket of red paint -
- and an unopened one with white paint
from the shed -
- put them together with brushes and rags
in the backpack and went on my way.
The moss was easily dusted off.
On the narrowest part of the ravine,
I painted him full size, in profile -
- red like blood.
I left the front teeming with crabs,
birds, matchstick figures -
- some of them on their knees in prayer -
- some with dicks sticking out
like small spears -
- one of the dicks bent at an angle -
- and when I painted it,
I started to laugh again.
At the studio, I stuck a tube of yellow oil
paint in my pocket and was stopped by Arne -
- who suddenly wanted me to prepare dinner!
I broke loose and painted a yellow star
over him at the ravine -
- and a yellow sun over the teeming figures.
I had no idea
how long the paint would stay -
- maybe some weeks, maybe months,
what did I know, maybe some years -
- whatever, the plan was to come back
and carve them into the mountain -
- that was easy, but not done quickly.
When I no longer could see details,
and the red had turned gray -
- I placed the backpack in the ravine
and went to the church.
This evening the new star was to appear -
- and what better place to see it
than outside the house of God?
Many thanks.
Thank you.